So as we continue to await results in many
states, we wonder how many mail in ballots
are out there in various states, we are getting
news that there could be hundreds of thousands
of missing ballots, missing ballots.
The U.S. Postal Service had a deadline of
yesterday to sweep their mail processing facilities
in more than a dozen states for missing election
ballots because of reports that ballots were
just sitting around.
They could be hundreds of thousands of total
ballots.
When you look at some of the margins in the
states still being counted.
You quickly realize hundreds of thousands
of that ballots could make a huge difference.
U.S. District Court Judge Emmet Sullivan in
D.C. ordered the sweep Tuesday morning when
the Postal Service said that its delivery
performance was down and they couldn't say
whether more than 300000 ballots received
had been delivered.
Well, then you've got to see if the ballots
are still at the postal center.
The sweep was supposed to happen in 12 specific
districts, including in Arizona, Florida,
Georgia, Pennsylvania, Texas, Wisconsin.
I think you understand the importance of this.
The judge gave the agency until three 30 p.m
to finish the task at four 30, the postal
service said, sorry, we couldn't do it, would
have disrupted our Election Day activities.
They said they would continue a daily review
process to find and deliver smaller amounts
of ballots.
We don't know how many ballots are currently
missing.
The window is closing very quickly.
The deadline for mail in ballots depends on
what state you were in, but it was Tuesday
night in a number of different states.
There are reports of undelivered ballots that
have started cropping up even from the past
weekend, Miami Dade County.
Listen, I'm not saying anything in particular,
but Miami-Dade County was expected to be more
pro Biden than the numbers bore out.
And Miami-Dade County is one of the places
where mail in ballots have allegedly gone
undelivered.
I'm just giving you the information.
This is a red alert in Pennsylvania alone,
one of every two ballots rejected in the last
election were because of a deadline and the
margin was only 44000 votes by which Donald
Trump defeated Hillary Clinton.
This has to be taken extraordinarily seriously.
This is just one example relating to potentially
three hundred thousand ballots that we know
of.
Look at the margins.
This is a potentially election changing number
of ballots.
These ballots could decide a state or two.
And these are exactly the ballots that Donald
Trump told us at 2:00 a.m. last night.
He is going to go all the way up to the Supreme
Court if he needs to, in order to stop the
counting of these ballots.
And Donald Trump wasting no time this morning
in starting the conspiracy theories.
Let's talk about that next